you've noticed they ramp up a difficulty
right so let's have a go at these
everyone should be able to do is sorry
these very first one right the very
first one I only have to do one thing to
both sides in order to get the king by
himself in order to solve per X what do
I do to both sides so tell me the answer
to what to do yeah good
I had to both sides that's going to get
rid of my minus 2 and when I put it on
the right-hand side were dads who I get
fantastic that's all you needed to do
right when you have a look at number 2
there's a little war going on but not
that much right what would you like me
to get rid of the 1 or the 3 first let's
get rid of one okay so if I take away 1
from both sides on the left that leaves
me win on going and on the right I again
now what do i do / division perfect so I
get nuts up okay by the way just quickly
remember we always know if a solution is
a solution or not because you can check
you can test if I put 3 it will work out
3 times 3 is 9 plus watch sure enough it
gives you 10 excellent alright now we
get to 3 & 4 pigs are really more
involved this is what we're doing just
in yesterday's lesson so I'm gonna start
question 3 up here I'm gonna meet
someone 5t minus 2 equals T plus 40 some
will give me a suggestion for a first
line yes
last few good so the minus two is one I
want to get rid of so I'm going to add
two to both sides that leaves me with
five T on the left and one on the right
okay now from there from there I have
the t's in two spots and I want them all
in one spot I want to click like taupe
so branda want to give you suggesting I
take away I minus T from both sides
right when I do that to the left hand
side that leaves me with five T's take
away 114 when I do it to the right that
T just disappears so I just get there to
the 16 last step divide by four okay
it's just these move at all
just a quick note before we leave this
question and you will be T as a premium
rule you'll be tan all the time I know X
is the most common one but Tina's come
up when you do write your T's I'm gonna
encourage you just like I have
if you don't normally write it put a
nice curly tail on your team so you
don't mix it up with a plus sign okay
T's come up enough that you might as
well know how to write them so you do
get confused
yes yeah sure ah the X the X I don't
really have that much of an answer for I
can't tell you there's a really easy
answer for why they use T because these
numbers right sorry I should say these
protein rules they represent numbers
that you don't know what they are right
like variables unknowns okay
two very common common numbers you want
to work out ah time and temperature both
of which start with T so when people are
my equations and like I want to find out
when something happens or what I want to
find out how old copper cotton is
they'll just use T so that's a bit of a
that's how language I guess annoying
sorry all right last one do I do lost
one or do you want to add something else
I kick shown now four is the hottest it
was the lunch from the last pot of last
exercise so that's why I snuck it into
the end
four minus y equals two y plus three
okay now I'm gonna try to approach it
the same way we did this previous one
right the first thing we do is we've got
rid of the number on the left hand side
that's a for more specifically it's a
plus for how do I get rid of all I take
away four okay so when I take away four
from this side I just get left with
minus y when I take my fall from this
side it's gonna be three take away 4
which is minus one your watch out these
negatives flying everywhere they can
really trip you up three minus four
that'll leave you of minus one great got
all the numbers over on the right hand
side now I need to get all the Y's on
the left hand side how do I get rid of
this 2y over here just like here you
took away a t for both sides I'm gonna
take away two Y from both sides I want
to get rid of two of them right so
you've got - why here like everybody's
why I might even write this line so my
head doesn't get you confused - Y minus
2y and then he our 2y minus 2y that's
just gonna disappear leave me with minus
one so what am I go to the left there -
why that's that's the negative and then
I go even more negative right it'll be
minus 3 y -3 1 that's equal to minus one
that's really tricky that's what makes
these questions hard with these negative
sign right and how they interact
I've got one last step now all right
just like I had here I need to divide by
something what should i / - minus three
so that's this right what happens to
those negatives they cancel each other
out right so I just get left with author